[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihnen allen die
Hochwasserlage in Deutschland bleibt
auch am vorletzten Tag des Jahres
kritisch die exakte Situation ist nach
wie vor regional sehr unterschiedlich
wir können uns das mal ein bisschen
genauer anschauen hier auf der Karte
sind die am stärksten betroffenen
Gebiete rot schraffiert im Zentrum nach
wie vor Niedersachsen die Stadt
Oldenburg bereitet eine mögliche
Evakuierung vor Clemenz Altmann beginnt
seinen Bericht in
Liliental etwa 120.000 Sandsäcke kleine
und große haben die Einsatzkräfte
bislang in Liliental verbaut
so soll verhindert werden dass im Falle
eines deichbruchs das Wasser weiter in
den Ort fließt doch sicher können sich
die lilientaler trotzdem nicht fühlen
weil er eben so instabil ist er ist
großflächig durchnässt und solange der
pigel nicht erheblich sinkt wde auch
eben nicht Trockner und damit eben auch
nicht stabiler Einsatzkräfte der
Feuerwehr haben am Nachmittag damit
begonnen Wasser aus der wörpe auf eine
nahegelegende Wiese zu pumpen auf diese
Weise soll der Fluss entlastet und der
Wasserdruck der seit Tagen auf den
Deichen lieg reduziert werden die
Landwirte aus der Umgebung helfen nach
Kräften nicht nur hier am Wasser sie
haben es drüben vielleicht gesehen was
da an Sand durch die Gegend gefahren
wird die ganzen letzten fün Tage wird
auch da teilweise rund um die Uhr Sand
bewegt die Landwirtschaft ist da wenn
sie gebraucht wird ohne die vielen
Helfer wäre liliiental wahrscheinlich
längst
abgesoffen wir haben bis zu 300
freiwillige am Sandsack verfüllplatz
auch die die dort mithelfen wir haben
ein unheimliches Engagement bei
Lohnunternehmern wir haben ein
unheimliches Engagement in der
Landwirtschaft auf einer Straßenseite
brennt Licht auf der anderen wurde der
Strom sicherheitshalber abgestellt mehr
als 300 Menschen mussten ihre Wohnung
verlassen Rückkehr
ungewiss auch wenn der befürchtete Regen
heute ausgeblieben ist die Pegel an den
Unterläufen der Flüsse in Niedersachsen
bleiben auf höchstem Niveau in Zelle
droht die aller über ihre Ufer zu treten
angesichts der hoch Wasserlage wird vor
Ausfällen der Energieversorgung gewarnt
auch das Mobilfunknetz könnte
zusammenbrechen einige Kilometer Fluss
abwärts bei Winsen können die
Einsatzkräfte keine LKW mehr an den
Deich bringen alles steht unter Wasser
der Untergrund ist schlammig
Kettenfahrzeuge übernehmen den Transport
der
Sandsäcke 130 km nordwestlich in hatten
bei Oldenburg ist die Hochwasserlage
weiterhin kritisch der Pegelstand der
Hunde ist un ändert hoch die Folge der
Deich wird weich muss verstärkt werden
der besondere Schutz gilt der Bahnlinie
nach osner Brücke einhubschrauber der
der Bundespolizei fliegt hier und sorgt
dafür dass bigpacks hier vom
Bereitstellungsplatz dann zum Einsatzort
geflogen werden um dann dort den Deich
zu stabilisieren und mit Gewicht halt zu
unterstützen aber die Gefahr ist nicht
gebannt die Stadt Oldenburg bereitet
deshalb eine mögliche Evakuierung des
Stadtteils achterd vor Einsatzkräfte
gehen von Haus zu Haus und informieren
die
Bewohner das neue Jahr hat noch gar
nicht begonnen da ist schon klar es wird
teurer für alle die essen gehen lieben
die Mehrwertsteuer auf Speisen in der
Gastronomie steigt zum Jahreswechsel von
7% zurück auf die üblichen 19% der Satz
war während der coronapandemie gesenkt
worden nach Angaben des
Branchenverbandes will die Mehrheit der
Wirte die Preise erhöhen welche Folgen
das ganze auch noch hat dazu wenja Domme
Christoph Elbert hat es satt lange hat
er versucht die Preise in seinem
Restaurant in Hannover günstig zu halten
doch die Mehrwertsteuererhöhung bringt
nun auch für ihn das Fass zum Überlaufen
wir haben die Preise die wir eigentlich
seit Corona hätten schon anziehen müssen
haben wir immer nicht ganz durch wir
haben noch die Energiepreise nicht
umgesetzt wir haben die
personalkostenpreise nicht umgesetzt da
ist bei uns Kraft noch eine Lücke jetzt
müssen wir noch die 12% erhöhte
Mehrwertsteuer auf Lebensmittel
generieren und das wird schwierig für
viele Restaurantbesitzer zudem ungerecht
die unterschiedlichen Steuersätze bei
der Bewirtung so zahlen Restaurants die
Speisen am Tisch servieren und damit
eine Dienstleistung erbringen ab 1.1
wieder
19% wird bei einer Bäckerei oder beim
Imbis am sttisch gegessen werden nur 7%
fällig sobald der Kunde aber sitzt sind
es wieder 19 Speisen Z mitnehmen oder
die geliefert werden gibt es wieder zum
ermäßigten Satz auch das Schulessen
könnte teurer werden zumindest wenn der
Caterer wie hier auch das
ausgabepersonal stellt damit höher
besteuert wird und diese Mehrkosten
weitergibt wir haben aktuell 4,80 € das
ist für die meisten Eltern schon fast
gar nicht mehr stemmbar kommen dann so
im Schnitt auf 5,30 € das ist für mich
in meinen Augen eine riesenkatastrophe
in erster Linie natürlich für alle
Eltern die Schulessen bezahlen müssen im
Zuge der coronakrise war die
Mehrwertsteuer in der Gastronomie von 19
auf 7% ges und die maßnme wegen der
Energiekrise verlängert worden diese
Ausnahmeregelung läuft nun aus für den
deutschen Hotel und Gaststättenverband
eine fatale Entscheidung also ausweilich
der Umsatzsteuerstatistik haben wir in
den ersten beiden pandemiejahren bereits
36.000 Steuerpflichtige Unternehmen
verloren und ich befürchte es werden
mehr werden laut unseren Umfragen ist
für nächstes Jahr ein Verlust von 12000
weiteren Unternehmen hier ermittelt
worden alles Schwarzmalerei Kontern
Ökonomen die Steuervergünstigung sei als
Krisenhilfe gedacht gewesen eine
dauerhafte Subvention nicht sinnvoll
vielen Branchen geht es nicht besonders
gut in diesen Tagen denken sie ans
Handwerk an den Einzelhandel an andere
Dienstleister die alle könnten kommen
und sagen wir brauchen jetzt aber eine
steuerleichtung die bekommen das aber
nicht Christoph Elbert wird sein
Restaurant erstmal für dre Monate
schließen aus Protest wie er sagt und um
sich zu überlegen wie asronomie in
Zukunft für ihn und seine Gäste
funktionieren
kann wenn ostdeutsche zu Weihnachten und
Neujahr jetzt in ihre alte Heimat
zurückkehren dann erwartet Sie nicht nur
ein Fest im Familienkreis und vielleicht
nostalgische Gefühle sondern auch eine
Aktion der Städte und Gemeinden dort
nach Hause kommen und bleiben das ist
das Ziel angesprochen sollen sich alle
fühlen die es gen Westen zog weil dort
die Jobs waren das Geld
die Zeiten haben sich geändert viele
Regionen zwischen Ostsee und Erzgebirge
suchen jetzt händeringend Arbeitskräfte
es gibt wieder Perspektiven nur muss das
auch allen klar werden Guben in
Brandenburg ist dabei besonders aktiv
Katrin Lentner Guben Grenzstadt zu Polen
an der Neise nach der Wende hat die
Stadt über die Hälfte der Einwohner
verloren damit es wieder anders wird
darin arbeitet kirtin geilich gerade
jetzt kommen viele der einzigen Kinder
der Stadt auf heimatbesuchben sie
zurückgewinnen damals war es so dass
Leute weggegangen sind vor 20 Jahren 30
Jahren und jetzt hat sich das so gedreht
dass wir hier jeden mit Freude empfangen
eine Messe haben sie auf die Beine
gestellt firmenverwaltung
Wohnungsgenossenschaft und Krankenhaus
alle suchen Personal die Türen sind
geöffnet für Menschen wie Familie Schulz
aus Kassel sie wollen s zurück nach
Guben zurück zu ihren Eltern und
geschwistn Haus bin halt die Ferne
runter nach Kassel gegangen hab da
Berufsausbildung gemacht damals war dann
bei Bund gewesen viele Jahre
Auslandseinsätze gemacht und habe mich
dann neu orientiert und arbeite jetzt im
strafalz durch die Ferne durch die 600
km lernt man das halt schätzen was wie
wichtig Familie ist und von daher haben
wir gesagt nee dann ziehen wir jetzt
zurück jetzt ist gerade guter Zeitpunkt
beide können in Brandenburg arbeiten
jetzt suchen Sie noch einen
Ausbildungsplatz für den 17-jährigen
Sohn vieles ist wieder möglich gben biet
Stellen vom Arzt Bäcker Handwerker bis
zum pfahrer industriejobs Entstehen
rocktech will auf diesem Gelände
litiumhydroxid für Batterien erzeugen
und der snackhersteller von BFI plant im
nächsten Jahr sein Produktionsstart in
Guben wir haben ein herausragendes
Wirtschaftswachstum in Brandenburg in
den letzten Monaten und Jahren gehabt
wir wollen diese gute Entwicklung weiter
fortsetzen aber Wirtschaftswachstum
braucht zusätzliche Fachkräfte das W
alles entscheiden denn der
Bevölkerungsrückgang trifft besonders
hart den Osten Deutschlands in einigen
Gebieten bis zu - 200% Abwanderung und
zu wenig Geburten fordern ihren Preis
das heißt der Arbeitskräftemangel wird
auf jeden Fall bis ungefähr Mitte der
30er Jahre noch zunehmen danach hat man
so eine leichte Entspannung für junge
Studentinnen wie Franziska Schuster gab
es lange nicht so gute Perspektiven wie
jetzt in ihrer Region ich möchte ja auch
wegen meinem sozialen Umfeld was ich
hier habe wieder zurück und ich meine
ich habe jetzt einen Beruf der jetzt
hier noch nicht so angesiedelt ist also
gerade Lebensmittelindustrie ist jetzt
hier noch nicht so groß und umso schöner
dass jetzt wieder Perspektiven gibt auch
größere Unternehmen die Stadt wirbt mit
kitaapätzen preiswerten Wohnungen und
Arbeitsplätzen in der Hoffnung dass
genügend Menschen nach Guben kommen und
auch
bleiben so und jetzt müssen wir auf den
ukrainekrieg gucken und dazuächst auf
die Lage im Osten der Ukraine wo es nach
gestern wieder russische Angriffe
gegeben har kundula ja und wieder sind
es zivile Ziele die im Osten der Ukraine
getroffen wurden 16 Menschen wurden
verletzt als russische Raketen in harkiv
und mikolajev Wohnhäuser und ein Hotel
trafen außerdem haben russische Behörden
aus der Grenzregion belgorot einen
größeren Angriff aus der Ukraine
gemeldet durch den Beschuss sein 18
Menschen getötet worden Kiev äußerte
sich nicht dazu Moskau drohte mit bestra
und forderte eine Sitzung des
unserheitsrates der zuvor die
großangelegten russischen Angriffe auf
die Ukraine mehrheitlich verurteilt
hatte Israel wird von Norden her
zunehmend bedroht durch die libanesische
hisbolla jetzt hat Benny ganz von der
stärksten
Oppositionsfraktion Deutschland gebeten
diese Bedrohung mit abzuwehren im
Gazastreifen dauern die heftigen Kämpfe
zwischen israelischer Armee und
radikalislamische Hamas an nach
israelischen Angaben sind noch
129 Geiseln in der Gewalt der
Hamas bundesinnenministerin fäer hat ein
hartes Durchgreifen der Polizei bei
möglichen silvesterkrawallen angekündigt
dem Tagesspiegel sagte sie niemand wolle
sinnlose Gewalt erleben in vielen
Städten wurden wie hier in Köln die
Einsatzkräfte noch einmal verstärkt seit
einem Alarm für den Kölner Dom gelten
strenge
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen in Serbien fand
heute rund zwei Wochen nach den
Parlamentswahlen die bislang größte
Demonstration gegen mutmaßlichen
Wahlbetrug statt in der Hauptstadt
Belgrad protestierten tausende Menschen
gegen die wiedergewählte Regierung unter
Präsident wuc und forderten
Neuwahlen Glitch das ist ein bisschen
früh neuoch Deutsch und ein bisschen
jeddisch rutschen weggleiten bei
Computerspielen werden so Programmier
und Grafikfehler beschrieben es ist also
das Ergebnis einer technischen
Fehlfunktion und es ist Kunst denn die
angesehene Münchner Pinakothek der
Moderne feiert diese Glitches mit einer
ganzen Ausstellung die Kunst der Störung
und die Frage ob absolute technische
Perfektion überhaupt erstrebenswert ist
Jutta sonneewal
es kracht es kratzt es
klirt was wir sehen ist verschwommen
verzerrt
verpixelt technische Pannen für
Künstlerinnen und Künstler sind solche
digitalen Ausrutscher also Glitches
längst ein spannendes und unterhaltsames
Feld normalerweise gucken wir durch
diese Oberflächen hindurch und sehen
etwas dass sich vor einer Kamera
befunden hat und nun werden wir von den
Künstler dazu aufgefordert einmal auf
diese Oberflächen zu schauen und
entdecken dabei Momente die den Medien
eigentlich immer inne sind die wir aber
nicht sehen oder auch übersehen die
Münchner Pinakothek der Moderne hat der
glitchart eine Sonderausstellung
gewidmet mit Kunst von über 50 Kreativen
aus der ganzen Welt allen gemeinsam der
Mut mit gewohnten Sichtweisen zu
brechen die französische Künstlerin m
z.brend Corona lockdowns die Welt mit
Google Streetview durchkämmt immer dann
wenn die Kameratechnologie versagte
machte sie einen
Screenshot ich sah Menschen die in zwei
geschnitten wurden oder in den Straßen
verschwanden das spiegelte genau das
zerrissene Gefühl wieder dass ich zu
diesem Zeitpunkt
empfand alle gingen in der Pandemie in
einer Zeitschleife
verloren Wahrnehmung Wirklichkeit wo
sind die Grenzen was ist wahrhaftig
damit experimentieren die Künstlerinnen
und Künstler sie wollen mit ihren
Glitches aufrütteln und provozieren
nicht nur im ästhetischen
Sinn es betrifft auch sexuelle
Orientierung es betrifft aber eben auch
geschlechtliche Identität und das ist ja
das nächste große Thema unserer Zeit es
geht aber auch um Themen wie Kriege und
die Auswirkung davon sowohl auf der
psychischen Ebene auch auf der
physischen Ebene was es bedeutet immer
wieder alles zusammenzubauen nur um es
wieder zerstört zu sehen verschwommen
und verschleiert die Bilder des
japanischen Künstlers Kazuma obara
fotografiert nah tchernobil mit alten
Strahlen verseuchten
Filmrollen so wird der Schmerz und das
Leid der atomaren Katastrophe auf
geisterhafte Weise
[Musik]
sichtbar der Fehler ist für mein Werk so
wichtig weil meine Vorstellung
das muss ich überwinden da bringt ein
Fehler zufällig andere Dinge hervor das
ist ein starker Teil der
Kunst scheitern als Chance und Teil der
Wirklichkeit zu sehen so macht die
glitschkunst den Blick frei für das
schöne
[Musik]
verborgene Wasser in einem
Eisenbahntunnel hat Tag vor Silvester
die Pläne viele Reisender platzen lassen
bei London waren zwei temsetunnel
überflutet deswegen hatte der Eurostar
Betreiber alle Züge zwischen London und
dem europäischen Kontinent gestrichen
tausende Reisende mussten Alternativen
suchen und in den Hochwassergebieten
hierzulande muss mit weiteren
Regenfällen gerechnet werden an
Silvester von Westen Wind und Regen
örtlich gewit in den Alpen Schnee ab
1300 m ganz im Osten erst neblich später
freundlich 5 bis 12° ähnlich mild
beginnt das neue Jahr dazu starker Wind
und oft Regen am Dienstag Schnee im
östlichen Bergland am Mittwoch auch ganz
im Norden fehlen noch die Zahlen zum
Glück die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto sie
lauten 4 26 41 44
4748 Superzahl 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen
auf Lotto zfde und im ZF Text ja liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer in einer
halben Stunde bricht der letzte Tag
dieses Jahres an Zeit um noch mal
durchzuatmen abzuschließen mit
2023 und zumindest was die
katastrophennachrichten aus aller Welt
angeht zu hoffen dass uns allen ein
Neuanfang gelingt ab dem ersten
wir sind auch im kommenden Jahr für Sie
da
versprochen und von uns allen hier in
Redaktion Produktion Technik in Regie
und im Studio einen guten notsch und bis
nächstes Jahr tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss